[MUSIC PLAYING]
MALE SPEAKER: The Golden Gate
Bridge 75th anniversary,
wanted everyone in the world
to be able to participate.
So the mass API is such a
great platform now that
everyone uses, almost
on a daily basis.
So it made total sense to do
something based on this API.
MALE SPEAKER: It was definitely
a challenge
figuring out how we were going
to get all of these
bridges to line up.
We prototyped it using
just paper, at first.
MALE SPEAKER: One hurdle that we
had was figuring out how we
could legally use the images
from Google Maps itself.
MALE SPEAKER: Being able to
speak with someone like Josh
at Google was critical for us
to get past certain hurdles.
FEMALE SPEAKER: We wanted it to
be something that was easy
for people to find a bridge
without having to use too many
brain cells.
And we seem to be having,
for example, a
burst now in Russia.
And we've had bursts
in Southeast Asia.
We started with a giant
burst in Brazil.
It's just been really
interesting to see how it's
traveled around the world, and
grown organically on its own.
[MUSIC PLAYING]